[Applause]
i love your story about your mom's
lasagna
and how she would make it for you
growing up and then you put it on the
menu at lola will you ever come and
teach i'll i'll come and make lasagna
with you deal
[Laughter]
okay thank you michael okay here we go
so first thing you already have a pot
going with everything simmering i just
want to show everybody at home how we
got to where you are
so in this in this pot i have all the
cut vegetables i have fennel
onion leek carrot celery and then my
little herb
bundle of rosemary thyme i put a little
bit
of chili flake in there a nice pinch of
salt
and then one quart of water
and two cups of crushed tomatoes
and then this just goes on and simmers
this is like the easiest
soup in the world once this simmers for
45 minutes through that's what you have
in front of you and the beauty about
this soup i think too though
is i kind of if i'm long on something
in the fridge like if if i have a bunch
of fennel or
something that i haven't used up throw
it in you know just kind of
have some fun with it so so now
like in front of you you have this i'm
going to take out my
little herb bundle
and i'm going to add i have some kale
kale going i have some snap peas that i
cut up
snap peas that's very different i really
love that ingredient
and then some zucchini i love it we have
diced
and now if you were going to do this
with dried chickpeas you would have put
them in in the beginning with everything
else
i just add some canned chickpeas so i'm
going to add those now
adding chickpeas and this goes back on
our stove
to simmer now at this point this could
simmer for about
10 or 15 minutes but really in about
three minutes it'll be ready to go
this smells like a beautiful herb garden
it's just gorgeous
well too a lot of times people will say
what's the biggest difference between
you know food that i get at a restaurant
and food that i make at home or how do i
make myself a better chef or even how do
i use less salt
fresh herbs fresh herbs will change your
life
it's like dry herbs are fine but fresh
herbs just give the
food life um all right we're going to
make the pea stew
all right so peace too now classically
pea stew is a it's an
herb sauce similar to like a pesto so
i i have the parsley sage rosemary and
thyme
also a very nice song um and i'm gonna
do it
in a food processor
and then once it kind of starts to chop
up a little bit
then i'm gonna put in my olive oil
and i'm gonna give it one pulse with oil
then you can add the cheese and it just
comes together really nice
and that's it so now i put i put a
little lemon in mine
lemon is just it if you finish anything
off with lemon it's a good thing
so you can add the lemon as you need it
um but yeah that's it
well i have this gorgeous pea stew here
give a piece to a taste tell me what you
think of it just by itself
well i went to give it a little lick
ended up shoving the whole thing in my
mouth so that should tell you everything
i really want it on a crostini right now
too like a nice
that would be good like how about if it
was like peak of summer
a grilled crostini with a little slice
of tomato on there with the pistol and
some crunchy sea salt
yes you mean i'm all done
um okay wow okay so now that we have our
pea stew
and now that our soup has been
beautifully simmering now
we put it in the bowls i love the color
of the broth
it's almost like a orangey rosy
gorgeous tone so the reason the way that
i put this on
is i just grab the spoon i give the
pistou
a little stir and then i just drizzle
it on top and just roll it right around
there
and you could see now you get you know
you could see some of the cheese you get
the
bright the the nice red orange
look at you drew it's not like a big
dumpy mess
it's like beautiful little dots i feel
like i'm gonna get little dollops with
each bite
that's so helpful yeah and then you're
just in a little bit more control of the
whole situation
if you wanted to put some additional
parm on you could do that you know now
you're in a place where you could
this would be great with just some nice
crunchy french bread would be delicious
so you could really have fun with it you
know what i'm gonna do with this michael
in honor of you you got me into a google
search last night because i heard that
one of your favorite treats
is potato chips maybe even salt and
vinegar with
lawson salt and vinegar chips yes oh god
you have it
i do i made some because i thought not
only do i want to learn and understand
what lawson's dip is uh it's eight
ounces of sour cream eight ounces of
cream cheese and three tablespoons
of dry ranch seasoning is that right
basically yeah yeah that's the basic
run-up of it it's
in cleveland there's a company that
makes this dip called lawson's
and it's like you grew up eating it and
you know as i became
a chef everyone's like oh do you only
eat fancy food do you
i'm like oh no man salt and vinegar
chips lawson's dipped
all day i also thought that these two
might pair well together
and i grew up eating lipton's french
onion dip
and so i had to try this it's incredible
all right i'm gonna taste the soup
this is so beautiful
thank you this is the most
um
oh my gosh that yes okay so this is what
happened
i wanted you to see our new buddy drew
real quick look look at our new guy
can you see him and say hi douglas
say hi
dougie and lucy michael this suit is um
one of the best soups i've ever had in
my life and that is not hyperbolic
it is it feels like i'm eating something
healthy and yet it feels so
just delicious this is perfect you're
amazing
will you please come back and teach us
your mother's lasagna that i know is a
dish very close to your heart
of course i will be back to dumont
lasagna and we'll do a garden tour in
the spring
that would be great and thank you you've
changed my life with lawson dip
i love it you're gonna be angry about it
later but it's okay now
i'm gonna oh i'm gonna pay for it
michael
but you know what as long as it's worth
it i'll pay the price
thank you michael seider thanks